I love these, uh, what do you call it? The, um, the,
the like finales and. Like they bring out the,
like, anytime a show ends, like, it's weird. How, like,
so after it, it's like
the, during the show of, of whatever,
your talk of whatever you're talking about. Star Wars, game of Thrones,
anything is like, during it, you don't realize how dorky it is.
And then afterwards you really realize how dark it is.
So like I'm on season five of game of Thrones. I don't, I don't, you know,
I don't, I don't, I'm not caught up,
but I know that finale was obviously this past weekend and
people are upset with the way it is. First of all,
it's so hard to sustain a show for eight seasons. Okay.
Um,
I know that because every show I've been on has been canceled after three or
two. Okay. But, um.
There's.
Petition, there's a petition to redo
the last season of game of Thrones.
Like, look that up.
Sophie Turner slams fan petitioned to remake game of Thrones, season eight.
Like,
do you understand the level of
glasses pushing up dorkiness? You are.
Um, do you understand the level of,
look
you are the level of, excuse me.
I was actually in line level of, you know,
it just makes me laugh. Dorky you are
is, is off the charts, dude. It's that flying jump. Kick off the charts from,
Oh, you're you're off.
You're off screen coming in in the dork mobile
to be like, dude, we gotta, we gotta start the petition.
I mean, you're the guy outside of the Lakers staple center,
protesting about the Lakers management. Hey, you're the first to go.
They're not going to remake seasons of game of Thrones.
They're not going to make another episode.
Maybe in 10 years they might make a prequel or some.
But do they're not going to make a a million people signed it.
A million of you are the first to go.
A million of you just exposed yourself. You're the first to go
line up. You're on the front line.
Okay.
When someone says, when someone says, Oh dude,
they got to remake the season eight of, of game of Thrones.
And I'm going to sign the petition. You say, you,
you say, get out there. That's what you say to them. And they say, what?
And you say, well, you're the you're on the frontline dude.
You're not going to be making decisions.
People tell you what to Dell
Dude, I signed. Did you sign up? Oh, you one of the million people here you go.
Get out there. Here's a gun. Here's a gun.
Get out there. Protect our minds,
protect our decision-making minds. EU.
Dude.
Are you me?
Imagine taking a pen or signing in
logging in. Wow. This matters enough to me.
Remake season eight of game of Thrones.
Bro. No.
They did it. You watched it Sega. It didn't end the way you liked it.
And guess what? Make a show,
make a show where it ends the way you want it to end. Make that show.
As a matter of fact, get all the people together. Remake game of Thrones.
You got a million of you remake game of Thrones, season eight.
So I'm telling you petition. There's a million of you that signed.
Did that sign, did that. You guys signed it. That
How about this?
You get together and you remake season eight of game of Thrones.
You do that all watch that you do that.
As a matter of fact, I guaranteed.
How much will people watch that Sophie Turner is putting a viral petition,
requesting a, got season eight remake on blast.
It's disrespectful to the crew and the writers and the filmmakers who have
worked tirelessly over 10 years. You know, you dorks.
He go get out there at a boy. Yo.
You're about to get shot in the head for our mind.
Look at this.
Look at this and people from different languages, just being dorks. Look,
someone just commented, please under it.
Like that's going to help somebody just commented under the re remake,
the petition things, please. Hey man,
you're literally the first to go. You're literally guy who gets the first gun.
What happened here? Here, dude, out there soldier. Why am I the first one?
Oh, you, you wrote please. Under the petition,
you thought you thought you should sign in.
You gave him your email ping and you signed in under the petition and
remake game of Thrones. Season eight,
you wrote P L E S E
here or get out there. Well, okay. I don't really understand, but.
You didn't even give him a helmet. No, I know. He's just a, he's a, Oh God.
You know why?
It's cause he's a idiot and he's the biggest glasses pushing up.
Dork of all he's from the thing is dude, he was the mayor of dorks, Phil.
That's why that's what happened. He was the mayor.
Of, of cucks.
Landing. That's why,
I mean, do it come on, man.
I don't like what they did to dinner.
It's she was the hero for 90% of the series. And you know, it's like,
this makes me laugh. How.
Okay.
I just don't like, you know, it's like, it's like scroll up.
So we get another one here. You know,
it's like even the writer sent through the final season was it was supposed to
be the fact that there are almost 1.5 million people signed.
Okay.
That's the guy looking for his arm and saving private Ryan. That's that guy.
That's what he's saying.
The earlier seasons were magical because the writers were had, you know,
all the published books and worked for references and is actually poorly
written. It rushed with abandoned storyline arcs. And that's the,
that's what the guy's saying,
looking for his arm on the opening scenes and that when you're storming the
beaches of Normandy, when it's the woman, the beach in Normandy
and the, uh,
in the saving private Ryan movie did how,
how dorky was it when people were thought it was funny to say saving, Hey,
have you seen saving Ryan's privates?
Yo dude.
There's a porno named of that for sure.